je dirais harmonie harmonie avec le lieu
avec le pays
anciennement c'était très important puis
ils ont aidé beaucoup de familles à les
familles étaient pas
et
une chocolaterie l'agriculture il y
avait un district et qui est plus eu non
plus de cinq ans
et
et là
à
pas
notre dame technibel est situé en plein
coeur de la drôme provençale à une
vingtaine de km de montélimar
fondée en 1937 c'est un des plus anciens
monastères cisterciens de france un
ordre qui a toujours accordé une grande
importance au travail de la terre
aujourd'hui sur un domaine de 500
hectares seulement une cinquantaine sont
cultivés par les moines dans trois
autres au sec dessus on attendra un peu
pour arroser
nous avons commencé à mettre des chênes
truffiers il ya une trentaine d'années
et cette année nous avons continué à
faire des plantations de truffes les
comme vous pouvez voir ici pour en vue
de récolter si possible des truffes
d'ici 10 20 ou 30 ans les grandes
cultures
c'est pour tout le monde pareil ça ne
rapporte plus beaucoup on se maintient
les cultures peut-être plus tard aurait
droit à produire tel de la truffe halle
et avoir un petit revenu voilà
dès les origines dans les monastères
cisterciens le travail manuel pour tous
les moines et les frères convers était
important et comme on était au moyen-âge
le travail principal c'était
l'agriculture puisque c'était la
principale source de revenu au 12e
siècle à l'origine des cisterciens
peut-être qu'une particularité
d'aiguebelle c'est que les terres autour
du monastère ne sont pas riches
donc il y avait certaines terres
cultivées on en sait aussi qu'ils
avaient des troupeaux de chèvres de
moutons de l'élevage mais très vite dès
le douzième siècle les moines
d'aiguebelle ont dû aller chercher des
terres plus éloignés par exemple dans la
vallée du rhône et nell possédée de
domaine dans la vallée du rhône
un autre domaine au xiiie siècle près
d'orange ou les frères pouvaient se
fournir en huile d'olive en vignes tous
ceux qui ne poussait pas ici à côté du
monastère
quand les moines sont revenus après la
révolution très vite aussi et peut-être
que là c'est une particularité
d'aiguebelle ils ont insisté sur les
industries parce que l'agriculture les
terres ne devait pas être suffisante
pour nourrir d une communauté qui
rapidement va devenir importante
puisqu'il y aura plus de 200 moines à la
fin du 19e siècle
on va construire un bâtiment dans la
deuxième moitié du 19e pour accueillir
une minoterie très vite cette minoterie
dans les années 1880 va se transformer
en chocolaterie et là y'a des photos où
l'on voit un petit peu l'importance de
cette industrie puisqu'il ya eu jusqu'à
200 ouvriers des avirons qui y
travaillaient tellement tellement
importante qu'il a fallu la délocaliser
déjà au début du 20e siècle la
transférer dans la ville voisine de
donzère met donc ça montre que dès la
fin du 19e siècle av ed mail vivait
principalement dans l'industrie et non
de l'agriculture comme dans d'autres
communauté cistercienne
après la première guerre mondiale la
chocolaterie petit à petit et passer à
d'autres mains et dans les années 1930
on a essayé une filature une fabrique de
couverture puis très vite je crois vers
1930 4,35 une distillerie petit à petit
cette distillerie s'est développée et
c'est elle qui a fait vivre la
communauté jusqu'à tout récemment
jusqu'en 1996
depuis c'est aussi finalement une forme
d'industrie qui continue à nous faire
vite puisque c'est la fabrication de
l'addiction la fabrication du boom donc
des produits artisanaux mais c'est pas
l'agriculture qui nous fait vivre
brou de noix chardon béni menthe poivrée
fleur de sureau sont quelques-unes des
50 de plantes qui rentre dans la
composition de la lections le produit
phare du monastère depuis 1996 pendant
la décoction au cellier on prépare
d'autres mélange savoureux
je savais que c'est fait
le premier c'est le cassis c'est
important après le citron après encore
d'églantier et enfin le caramel
les quatorze à douze membres
trente cinq moines de 33 92 ans forment
la communauté des quais belle ici vivent
ensemble travaille ensemble et prient
ensemble des italiens des polonais des
canadiens des camerounais et des
français isolée du monde extérieur
la charge principale de travail repose
sur un noyau de huit moines les plus
jeunes de la communauté le travail des
frères représentent près de 60% des
revenus de l'abbaye
le reste se partageant entre retraites
des anciens et demande de cette fois non
je pense qu'il faut vivre avec notre
temps donc être compétitif si on veut
pouvoir vivre et vente de produits mais
sans perdre nos valeurs et sans perdre
ce qui est l'essentiel de notre vie je
pense pas que l'économie le travail est
un point important de la vie
cistercienne et l'a toujours été mais
c'est pas l'essentiel de notre vie donc
faut pas que ça devienne l'essentiel de
représentant environ quatre heures de
prières cet office rythme la journée du
moine des pelles de 3h30 du matin à 20
heures le soir
mr
chaque moine participe à tours de
rouleaux tâches quotidiennes de l'abbaye
être au service des autres frères fait
partie de leur devise
nous voulons de l'élection comme ça
certains en ont besoin donc ils ne
boivent pas du vin qui prêtent de
l'élection la place était embêtant de la
gestion comme je le dis par ailleurs
nous mettant des bouteilles l'élection
qui sont pas commercialisable à cause
d'un petit défaut sur la capsule ou bien
sur l'étiquette comme ça à l'om il ya
pas d'étiquette c'est très varié nous
mettons notre édition chaque achat
tablerait press le dimanche il ya
toujours
trop peu nombreux pour assurer la
préparation des repas
les moines d'aiguebelle ont décidé de
les sous traiter à un restaurateur de la
région
architecture épurée simplicité du
mobilier tout ici est en osmose avec les
voeux de silence et de pauvreté
hier
deux ans
le
au réfectoire on nourrit le corps et
l'esprit
une lecture choisi par le père abbé
accompagne le repas pris en silence nous
pensons désormais raison de nos
questions et bouquets
à la différence de la plupart des autres
ordres
il n'existe pas de temps de détente
fraternelle où récréation chez les
cisterciens de la stricte observance
être ensemble se vit toujours dans le
silence
l'homme se construit en travaillant
beaucoup soutenir la campagne est donc
c'est important que que je conserve
l'entraînement tu ici pendant presque
vingt ans j'aime le troupeau de kobe
était à notre travail
alors c'était un peu spécialisés je ne
faisais que ça en gros toute l'année
avec l'émetteur
il ya des produits qui sont qui sont
compétents il donne de l'appétit
parce qu'il ya des plantes qui stimule
l'appétit sans alcool et et d'autres
plantes qui au contraire facilite la
simulation
depuis d'autres choses qui complète et
ce qui fait que c'est assurément très
bon pour tout le monde
si la consommation idéal je dirais c'est
l'hiver ont fait divers tout ces gens
mais si on a une grosse fatigue d'une
grosse crise comme ça si on veut se
remonter alors on peut en fait une cure
le nez le mieux c'est de faire une pure
trois semaines quatre semaines verra
chaque repas ou même un petit peu avant
le repas vers ça fait un bon effet
j'ai bientôt 50 ans de vie monastique
c'est déjà en banque il y en a qui sont
plus vieux que moi dans la maison à tous
points de vue
mais enfin ça fait ça fait déjà pas mal
je trouve le 50 ans si on peut tenir
dieu nous tiens mais il faut y mettre du
sien quand même il faut le reconnaître
il ya des jours c'est pas si facile il
faut fois il met du sien
dans les monastères nous vend nous
entrons à différentes pages certains ont
des compétences qui peuvent être
directement utiles à la communauté
j'ai une formation d'ébéniste j'ai plus
lorsque j'étais novice faire un peu de
d'ébénisterie ici un peu de mobilier ce
qui en avait besoin et que j'avais la
possibilité de temps mais à présent
c'est très très exceptionnelle que je
reviens dans ce lieu ayant d'autres
charges qui m'empêche d'avoir ce temps
disponible et donc tout ce travail de
bois de menuiserie ou de débit story se
fait maintenant les serres dans la
mesure où on a on a accepté au préalable
de de ne pas se fixer sur notre propre
compétence comme moyen de se valoriser
et comme moyen de s'épanouir
hong hong et détaché par rapport à notre
propre compétence
or me mets à la ferme j'avais jamais
fait sur sa famille olympiens oui j'ai
fait mabiala fusil fait la physique
maintenant me réchauffer l'eau limpide a
comme ils ont changé et que je
connaissais les chiens on me laisse le
paiera mais made man m occuper des
chiens vont venir ont truffé
ça vous change les idées les fins de
travail qui changea je trouve que c'est
une chaîne et marne
vous
moi j'ai de bordeaux le bon vin on voit
sa vie qu'on a vécu avant quand on est
ici non j'ai fait mon boulot j'ai
travaillé honnêtement j'ai chanté j'ai
chanté j'ai dansé j'ai dit j'ai vraiment
vécu comme il faut sur intra 46 voilà
quand tu es
les jeunes qui remplissent en était à
l'ordinateur ils ont le téléphone ils
ont atterri connaissent la sexologie la
sexualité tout ça c'est vraiment un
appel
alors les jeunes je les admire donc dû
renvoyer c'est quelque chose de
l'intérieur s'est pas être choqué qui
l'extérieur ccvq intérieurement la
cellule à cellule vous pensez à une
chambre d c'est le coeur la ceni s'il ya
quelque chose qui vous manque vous
partez ou incompatibilité d'humeur avec
quelqu'un pouvait pas rester vous il
faut savoir s'il faut se je pense se
déformer pour se former
c'est quand même un défi parce que c'est
une communauté où il ya plus d'anciens
que de jeunes donc il faut pas que le
travail prennent trop de place et il
faut garder d' équilibre qu'a voulu
saint benoît dans sa règle contre le
travail la prière entre travail la
prière et l'étude aussi donc c'est je le
vois plus actuellement comme un défi de
faire en sorte que le travail ne
prennent pas trop de place et qu'on
arrive à garder l'équilibré nasty
khorosan la journée à l'infirmerie
les anciens et les malades participent
avec leurs moyens au travail de la
communauté jeu l'aubépine pour le coeur
c'est un stimulant cardiaque excellent
excellent la camomille ou l'estomac
digestion et un calmant aux priorités ce
nettement le mélange intitulé minceur
alors là celui qui sera le plus défaut
plus
en quantité le mot dernier on a dû en
faire 800 quelque chose comme ça plus
les anciens vieillissent dans la suite
de jésus puis deviendra libre
intérieurement et je pense que la force
d'une communauté comme la nôtre où il ya
beaucoup d'anciens c'est cette capacité
de vivre la liberté intérieure dans un
grand climat de paix ils ont vu
tellement d'eau passer sous les ponts
que il ya plus beaucoup de choses qui
les désarçonne à 85 ans frère camille
s'occupe du café de koutaba aiguebelle a
fondé ce monastère au cameroun il ya
cinquante ans le monastère est située à
1200 mètres d'altitude et c'était le
lieu idéal pour la culture du café et le
cacao café que nous cultivons
c'est commercialisé en france par est de
belle
qui est comme un autre relais à ces
niveaux
nous venons trois fois par année pour
les sessions de théologie et nous
retournons au des temps en temps en
communauté à koutaba parce que notre
communauté essentiellement jeune la
lecture méditée de la bible est un
moment très important dans la journée du
moine chez les cisterciens d'aiguebelle
la lectio divina se fait au scriptorium
la lectio divina n'est pas le moment de
satisfaire tout simplement
l'intelligence mais plus encore le
moment opportun pour cultiver le jardin
du coeur quand je fais la lectio divina
je me compare toujours à un ruminant à
une chèvre qui ayant goûté à toutes
sortes d'herbes pendant la journée
revient le soin à l'abri au repos
hennebelle plus tout simplement elle
rumine elle rumine la parole c'est un
petit peu la base la nourriture de base
le matin j'ai besoin de déjeuner pour
tenir le coup mais j'ai besoin aussi de
cette lectio divina pour tenir le coup
aussi pour vivre pour vivre cette
journée qui servent qui commence
la force d'une communauté où plusieurs
générations se retrouvent c'est
précisément d'avancer ensemble dans
l'entente et la tente les uns des autres
il ya aussi tout de la figure du père
dans c'est un sujet que toujours plus
délicat que difficile à aborder pour un
père à d il faut savoir apporter cette
double dimension de tendresse
d'affection de compassion mais aussi de
fermeté
parce que encore une fois ce ne sont pas
des enfants qui me sont confiées ce sont
des frères qui acceptent librement dans
une démarche de foi de reconnaître que
je peux représenter le christ pour eux
mais rossi n'est pas seulement père dans
l'accompagnement des frères anciens mais
aussi des frères plus jeunes qui ont
besoin aussi de sentir non pas seulement
que la fermeté mais le conseil les
directives mais la présence aimante
il faut beaucoup peiné un frein pour
accepter de lui faire des remarques
encore une fois je pense que personne
aime recevoir des remarques
surtout lorsqu'elles ne sont pas très
positives pour aider à améliorer à vivre
autrement
et puis la communauté forme son abbé
c'est elle qui le choisit b à travers
ses silences ses absences et respecte
ans finalement elle façonne aussi son
habit
m
oh
il ya quand même beaucoup des crises
particulière d'aujourd'hui qui
souhaiterait en voir une présence
contemplative qui souhaiteraient avoir
des moines peut-être qu'on peut aider
des groupes de jeunes dans ces églises à
à s'initier à la voix qui est la nôtre
et là aussi tout un travail je pense
pour lequel on a un savoir faire en une
sagesse et c'est une manière de
transmettre notre vie
m
ouais
tout ça